since the december european council  turkey has shown a more constructive  attitude  including in its bilateral relations  with several  eu member states these are  positive and welcomed steps on which we  must try to build on  however we also know that this progress  of de-escalation  remains fragile so together with high  representative borrel  we submitted a report on the state of  play of eu turkey political economic and  trade relations  we will further engage with turkey on  issues such as migration financing  high-level dialogues and modernizing the  customs union  if turkey does not move forward  constructively  if it returns to unilateral actions or  provocations  in particular in the eastern  mediterranean of course  we would suspend these cooperation  measures